approval of item 66 the Humane pet store  ordinance please cast your votes  and motion carries  there you've heard and saw it cheers of  a long-awaited win we thank you for  joining us here on 8 news now I'm John  langler so we're going to start in the  Clark County Commission Chambers just  moments ago you just saw Commissioners  passed a new law outlawing the sale of  purebred animals in retail stores Animal  Advocates have been pressing for this  change for years they claim it creates a  cycle of inhumane treatment the Nevada  SPCA says many breeders are more  concerned about profit over health and  at the same time our shelters are  overcrowded  we have to be able to look at look after  these animals and I understand that  people do have pet stores that sell them  but you could sell other products  um now more than a dozen pet stores will  have a year to change their business to  only grooming and Retail Services  however they could also sell rescue  animals instead